hello and welcome to my basic PHP
tutorials so what is PHP PHP originally
stood for personal home page and later
it was kind of a appended to the end of
it hypertext processor so really PHP
nowadays stands for a PHP hypertext
processor or pH PHP but I guess they
just didn't like the sound of that so
anyway what's PHP used for PHP is really
just a general-purpose programming
language though it's most notably used
for web development and really what it
does is it's more of a server-side
scripting language and it's interpreted
by C basically or the server and so this
means like whenever someone use your PHP
page over the internet and they say go
to like new source they're not seeing
your PHP code they're just seeing the
HTML output from your PHP code so that's
basically how it works and what it's
used is ours and with that that kind of
leads into the next part most PHP
tutorials start off with the
installation of xampp and apache i don't
really think that that makes very much
sense if you're here to learn PHP to
like maybe just run stuff on your
computer then you've probably chosen the
wrong language maybe check out Python or
C or Java right but not PHP now if
you're gonna run maybe your own like an
unmanaged VPS or your own server you'll
need to know how to install Apache and
all that but chances are if you're
watching a beginner's PHP tutorial
that's not what you want to do so I'm
going to assume that you have some sort
of ability to host files if you know
there are plenty of online hosting
services that are free and then there's
also plenty of online hosting that's
really really cheap like most the time I
see on like GoDaddy you can buy a domain
and internet hosting for like a dollar
for a month so for
and in really if you're if you're
learning PHP I'm assuming that you
eventually want to have a website so or
at least understand the websites so the
best way to do this is not you know to
learn it on xampp and then once you get
comfortable with doing the xampp then
you're gonna have to learn how to use
okay get used in comfortable with using
some sort of FTP service and then also
whatever your hosting is and if you've
got like databases and you want to learn
how to do stuff like you know interact
with your database manually and all this
kind of stuff you've got it almost like
you it's like a fundamental thing right
how you edit of how you edit files and
like test them and stuff like that like
it's pretty fundamental so if you learn
on xampp and then you need to go to like
an actual website it just seems kind of
silly to me to learn on there when the
end goal is to be online so enough of
that I'm gonna be showing you guys I'm
going to edit with notepad plus plus you
can edit strictly with just a notepad
file if you want just make the file
extension be AHP but I highly suggest
notepad plus plus as its file name
suggests it's and it's an improvement
over a regular notepad and then also
I'll be using FileZilla to upload the
files I'll not really be showing you too
much within FileZilla but that's what
I'll be using to upload files to my
server so anyway but if you want you can
use xampp you can do whatever the heck
you want to do I'm just going to be
going through the PHP basics file if you
do do the FileZilla root that's what I
suggest you really just need to know
once you download FileZilla you'll need
your hosts IP address you'll need your
you know FTP username the password and
you can leave port empty and you just
hit quick connect and then I'll connect
you to the root of your hosting plan
basically or all your host files from
there you can go into whatever directory
you want to use so in almost all of my
tutorials will be single pages so you
won't really need to even do that it
doesn't really matter where you're going
to
them you should put them up there so you
can test them yourself so with that I'm
gonna go ahead and hop right on into it
and we ought to make at least a some
sort of code on the first tutorial or I
find it to be very depressing so what we
will do is you start off a PHP script
with PHP tags and those tags are
question mark PHP and then you close off
the tag with another question mark and
everything in here is read as a PHP
script and if it is not compliant with
the proper syntax you'll get an error so
let's do the first thing and the easiest
thing let's just echo out a statement
and do not worry I'm not gonna echo
hello world if you've ever learned any
sort of programming language in your
life you're probably sick and tired of
seeing hello world so instead we'll just
echo welcome to PHP and if you're coming
from Python you'll probably forget the
semicolons a lot I will forget
semicolons a lot I prefer Python that's
what I do most of my programming in so I
like to forget semicolons but otherwise
you know it's a string you close off the
string simple stuff really so whenever
you're done with it if you're using
FileZilla save it and then files will
say oh you changed a file and then
you'll upload the file and then you'll
come over to wherever your link is my
link happens to be my one of my websites
H Kinsley com I've got tutorial and then
PHP tutorials dot PHP and then this one
just says welcome to PHP so it just
spits it out on on door page so that's
going to conclude the first tutorial if
you have it installed FileZilla please
do install FileZilla if you don't
understand what's going on with
FileZilla or notepad plus plus feel free
to leave a comment I'll respond to it
but really both of them are pretty
simple pretty easy to use like I said
with FileZilla just just get once you
have a hosting plan in a domain and you
add that domain to your hosting plan
you'll have some sort of IP address
that responds to your domain you'll just
connect to that you'll use your username
password you'll enter that and then on
you should see kind of in the on the
right-hand side a big list of files or
just one if you only have one user in
era domain click on there and you can
just make a directory or whatever you
want to do and you can just easily click
and drag files into there so you can
make PHP tutorials on PHP click drag it
into that folder and then you can
actually visit that URL online the only
thing I will just say is if you are just
kind of toying around whenever you're
done toying around its unless you know
for sure that whatever you've coded is
is safe like if you've got some sort of
submit functionality or some sort of
connection to databases stuff like that
and you're just kind of toying around
the best thing for you to do is go ahead
and remove that file from the server
while you're not doing anything if
you're not certain it's a secure file
because you can kind of represent some
risks by leaving connections open if you
don't know what you're doing so anyway
with that stay tuned to the next
tutorial